[Music]
star wars fans got plenty of the things
they expected from the first teaser
trailer for the upcoming obi-wan kenobi
series set to debut on disney plus in
may fans have known since august 2019
that ewan mcgregor would be reprising
his role as the jedi master along with
hating christensen's return as darth
vader since the project was announced a
few years ago
hello there
however there were a few surprises in
the obi-wan kenobi trailer some fans
never expected chief among them were the
appearance of the inquisitors the
inquisitors are an order of
force-sensitive hunters that were
trained by darth vader in order to
capture kill or corrupt any surviving
jedi in the galaxy many of them appear
in star wars series like star wars
rebels as well as various related comics
and video games like star wars jedi
fallen order despite their popularity as
villains this is the first time that
they've appeared in a live-action
context similar to cad bane's appearance
on the book of boba fett however not
every star wars fan who watched rebels
is jumping for joy at the inquisitor's
live-action debut in fact it's the
appearance of the grand inquisitor that
has some fans scratching their heads
fans on reddit made it clear that this
live action grand inquisitor was close
to the version of the character we see
in star wars rebels but didn't quite
look right one user wrote i realize the
rebels style as a cartoonified stretched
out look but even so i would have
preferred him look a little thinner in
the face
another user observed he definitely
looks less slim than i thought he'd look
in live action
another responded that in rebels he
gives off the air of a diffident
aristocratic fencer i'm not getting that
vibe from him he looks like a haunted
house reject it's worth noting that the
grand inquisitor's species the powens
are notoriously slim and this character
is no exception in rebels he is depicted
as noticeably taller and thinner than
the majority of characters previous
live-action depictions of the powen
species are also extremely slim one
reddit poster wrote first thing i
noticed as well aren't their heads a
little longer too he didn't look much
like the powens from revenge of the sith
in my opinion this of course doesn't
mean that this new portrayal should be
automatically discounted cad bane's
appearance in the book of boba fett also
led to some minor fan outcry but was
overall well liked by at least a portion
of the viewing audience
consider this my final lesson
look out for yourself
now that we've seen what the obi-wan
kenobi version of the grand inquisitor
will look like it's important to go over
who exactly the inquisitors are in the
world of star wars as we mentioned they
are an order of jedi hunters trained by
darth vader to assist him in the jedi
purge following the events of order 66.
while their exact numbers aren't well
known quite a few make appearances in
rebels and other media putting aside the
grand inquisitor one of the other
inquisitors we see rendered in live
action for the very first time is the
fifth brother played by sung kang he is
the helmet sporting gentleman leading a
squad of stormtroopers at the one minute
15 second mark in the teaser trailer
he's also one of these several
inquisitors to make multiple appearances
in rebels another is riva a brand new
inquisitor whose story is thus far
unknown considering that she hasn't yet
made an appearance in any other star
wars media her fate is the most
ambiguous of the characters we've seen
in the trailer then of course there's
the grand inquisitor the leader of the
bunch who terrorized kanan jarrus and
ezra bridger on multiple occasions in
rebels a former jedi the grand
inquisitor is about as dangerous as the
empire gets without vader getting
involved
in other words his involvement in the
events of obi-wan kenobi spells big
trouble for both obi-wan and the young
luke skywalker thankfully that
intimidating presence is present in the
show's trailer we'll just have to wait
and see whether or not the fans will be
able to overcome his new look
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]